das ist wirklich eine absolute
katastrophe schon seit einem monat
funktioniert das weltraumteleskop hubble
nicht mehr nasa fachleute suchen
verzweifelt nach der fehlerursache die
nasa will mit allen mitteln die sie hier
von der erde hat das teleskop wieder
starten kann es also doch noch gerettet
werden klicks um science and future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
seit rund einem monat seit dem 13 0 62
01 21 gibt das weltraumteleskop hubble
quasi kein lebenszeichen mehr von sich
genauer gesagt fiel der sogenannte bot
computer aus also das rechenmodell mit
dem die wissenschaftlichen instrumente
antwort des teleskops kontrolliert und
koordiniert werden
der hauptcomputer tat was er tun musste
er versetzte alle instrumente in eine
art ruhezustand den safe mode alle
versuche den payload computer wieder zu
starten blieben erfolglos seitdem zieht
habe in einer höhe von etwa 550 km
ziemlich nutzlos seine bahn und lässt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auf der erde die haare raufen
nicht mal ein neustart des rechners
brachte den gewünschten erfolg genauso
erfolglos auch die suche nach der
ursache des ausfalls doch jetzt hat die
nasa am donnerstag dem 15 mit einem
spektakulären rettungsmanöver begonnen
sie glaubt den fehler gefunden zu haben
was also steckt hinter dem ausfall und
gelingt es tatsächlich unser auge im
weltall wieder zum leben zu erwecken
die antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es in
diesem video
die idee zur habe stammt von leimen
spitznamen professor an der renommierten
yale-universität wird seit 46 schritte
einen aufsatz in dem er ein
weltraumteleskop vorschlug da es bei
einem solchen teleskop keine störung
durch die erdatmosphäre gebe
20 jahre später 1966 wurde er dann in
ein komitee berufen um ein solches
teleskop zu planen wiederum knapp zehn
jahre später 1975 wurde das projekt vom
haushaltsausschuss des
us-repräsentantenhauses abgelehnt das
war zu teuer
dann begann spitzer und zahlreiche
kolleginnen kollegen mit lobbyarbeit und
leistete überzeugungsarbeit gleichzeitig
wurde die europäische
organisationen die heutige leser
dazugewonnen
die solarzellen zu bauen und das
teleskop wurde insgesamt etwas kleiner
geplant 1977 dann endlich wo das
genehmigt und mit dem bau wurde begonnen
1985 war es dann endlich fertig und
startbereit geplanter start oktober 1986
transportmittel sollte ein space shuttle
sein doch dann passierte die
schreckliche challenger katastrophe nach
dem start explodierte einer der
feststoff booster und riss die raumfähre
mit der gesamten mannschaft in den tod
erst fünf jahre später dann ging es
endlich für hubble in den weltraum
am 24 april 1990 startete das space
shuttle discovery und setzte das hubble
weltraumteleskop in einer rekordhöhe von
611 kilometern aus doch dann gab es eine
riesen enttäuschung habe war quasi
kurzsichtig das teleskop lieferte
unscharfe bilder beim schleifen des
hauptspiegels wein instrument fehlerhaft
und so wurde der gesamte spiegel falsch
geschliffen habe brauchte eine brille
und die wurde den weltraum teleskop dann
zweieinhalb jahre später verpasst dafür
musste wieder ein space shuttle zu
hubble fliegen und im kloster einbauen
was am zweiten dezember 1993 geschah
erst dann konnte habe seine arbeit
uneingeschränkt aufnehmen und liefert
und seitdem spektakuläre bilder aus dem
all und noch weitere vier missionen
flogen zu haben um es zu verbessern und
zu reparieren und jetzt das ende außer
frage wohl kein anderes weltraumteleskop
hat die astronomie so weit gebracht wie
habel habe hat es uns beispielsweise
ermöglicht die ausdehnung und das alter
des universums zu bestimmen auch
spannende infos zu fassen und der dunkle
materie hat uns das teleskop beschert
durch habe gab es die bestätigung dafür
dass gigantische schwarze löcher in den
zentren von galaxien sitzen und sich der
kosmos immer schneller ausdehnt diese
ausdehnung geschwindigkeit konnte zudem
mit nie zuvor erreichter genauigkeit
bestimmt werden haben wir in der letzten
zeit öfter über
die immer noch da vorherrschenden
ungenauigkeiten berichtet aber habe ist
eines der wichtigsten instrumente und
überhaupt diese hubble konstante
herauszufinden eines der ersten
spektakulären bilder gelangen habe fünf
jahre nach seinem start die rede ist vom
ersten sogenannten hubble deep field
durch eine lange belichtungszeit wurde
das bild möglich dass tausende von
galaxien zeigt und außerdem auch einen
blick in die vergangenheit so konnten
als promi teams quasi direkt sehen wie
galaxien entstehen
hubble hat uns außerdem gezeigt dass
albert einstein recht hatte die rede ist
vom sogenannten gravitationslinseneffekt
einfach gesagt große massen lenken licht
ab und genau das hatte schon albert
einstein mit seiner allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie vorhergesagt all
diese erfolge wurden möglich durch die
einzigartige kombination aus breitem
spektrum und sehschärfe von seinem orbit
aus rund 560 kilometer über der
erdoberfläche kahn habe in die tiefen
des alls blicken und das ohne von
atmosphärischen störungen beeinträchtigt
zu werden
dazu kommt die extrem hohe auflösung von
0,05 bogensekunden zehnfach höher als
die bei erdgas ihren teleskopen die
bandbreite seiner optik ist enorm habe
kann somit nicht nur energiereiche
strahlung heißt an gasnebel einfangen
sondern auch durch verhüllende
staubwolken blicken diese kombination
macht hubble einzig arzt bis heute nach
angaben der nasa sind in den rund 30
jahren haben mehr als achtung 18.000
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichungen
entstanden die wir allesamt dem
weltraumteleskop hubble zu verdanken
haben in seinem visier vor allem objekte
in unserem sonnensystem wie
beispielsweise asteroiden und planeten
monde aber auch besonders junge galaxien
aus der frühzeit des universums schon
lange ist klar das habe nicht für immer
unser auge im all sein wird sein ende
ist vorprogrammiert zum einen liegt das
an den extremen bedingungen im weltall
und zum anderen an der gravitation der
erde
das weltraumteleskop sinkt immer weiter
ab in 16 jahren 2037 dann spätestens
wird habe soweit abgesagt sein dass es
in die atmosphäre eintritt der plan der
nasa fachleute war eigentlich dann zu
entscheiden wie es mit hubble zu ende
gehen soll
zur auswahl stehen ein kontrollierter
absturz oder aber das parken in einem
höheren
stabilen orbit letzteres könnte mit
hilfe einer unbemannten sonde passieren
beide maßnahmen sollen verhindern dass
trümmerteile auf bewohnte region
stürzten den glas auch hubble wird
aufgrund seiner größe nicht komplett in
der atmosphäre verglühen
doch jetzt kommt alles vielleicht doch
ganz anders denn das weltraumteleskop
hat bereits seit wochen mit technischen
schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen
zwei monate nach seinem 31 geburtstag im
april an einem sonntag den 13 juni hatte
das teleskop gegen 22 uhr
mitteleuropäischer zeit seiner arbeit
eingestellt
zunächst hatten die nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
alles daran gesetzt haben wieder zum
laufen zu bringen
doch weder der neustart des pay what
computers zeigte den gewünschten erfolg
noch der versuch eines der drei reserve
speichermodule umzuschalten
die fachleute machten sich also auf
fehlersuche um die ursache des ausfalls
dingfest zu machen dabei darf man nicht
vergessen
die technik stammt aus den 80er jahren
damals gab es noch nicht mal pcs bis auf
den apple 2 ein computer der mit
tastatur befehlen bedient wurde
zunächst hatten sie die standard
interface hardware genauer ins visier
genommen dabei handelt es sich um ein
bauteil das die kommunikation zum
zentralen prozesse des playout computers
möglich macht das das stellte sich im
nachhinein als eine falsche fährte
heraus in der vergangenen woche hatte
die nasa mitgeteilt dass die
fehlerursache dingfest gemacht werden
konnte bedingt ist der technische
ausfall von hubble demnach durch die
sogenannte power control unit kurz bc
you es handelt sich um ein zweiteiliges
modul das die spannungs zu fuß zum
computer reguliert so dass diese
konstant 5 volt beträgt quasi das
netzteil sobald dies nicht gewährleistet
ist fährt sich der rechner herunter die
zahlreichen tests der nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
legten nahe dass es entweder beim
überwachungs kreislauf hakt oder der
abschalt befehl fälschlicherweise
ausgegeben wird denkbar ist nach ansicht
der fachleute aber auch dass die
kontrolle an hat keine akzeptable
spannung liefert fest steht die
sogenannte power control unit gehört zum
sogenannten science instrument command
and data handling hardware systemen
gemeint ist eine ganze reihe von
bauteilen die neben dem pilot computer
noch andere hardware beinhaltet das
ganze ist also leider komplizierter als
erwartet dennoch hat die nasa die
hoffnung noch nicht
aufgegeben und pläne für ein
rettungsmanöver entwickelt und dieses in
simulationen getestet das gute alle
bauteile der science instrument command
and data handling hardware sind doppelt
vorhanden es gibt also ein backup
bereits vor 13 jahren 2008 hatte die
nasa hat das bei einem defekt eines
hardware teils ausgenutzt und auf das
reserve modul umgeschaltet ein jahr
später also 2009 wurde das gesamte modul
also das kaputte module ersetzt wodurch
nun glücklicherweise ein neues backup
zur verfügung steht dennoch das
umschalten auf das backup dieser einheit
ist alles andere als einfach dazu
schreibt die nasa
die prozedur ist komplexer und riskanter
denn um auf den backup spannungs
regulator zu wechseln müssen auch
mehrere andere hardware module des
teleskops satelliten umgeschaltet werden
denn diese sind mit diesen modulen
verknüpft doch im jahr 2018 war es
gelungen auch die tests in den
vergangenen tagen geben anlass zur
hoffnung haben donnerstag dem 15 07
hatten die nasa fachleute dann also mit
dem rettungsmanöver bekommen dazu
schreibt die nasa auf ihrer website alle
testprozedur für das umschalten und die
damit verknüpften prüfungen sind
abgeschlossen und das nasa management
hat uns das grüne licht gegeben und man
darf dabei nicht vergessen das ist nicht
etwas was man täglich macht sondern vor
2008 12 13 jahren hat man das überhaupt
das letzte mal gemacht das heißt das
musste man quasi jetzt neu lernen kann
habe also doch wieder den betrieb
aufnehmen
die banken stunden des wartens begann
denn das war den fachleuten von
vornherein klar
selbst wenn die aktivierung der backup
module erfolgreich verläuft und die
umschaltung erfolgt ist müssen die
verschiedenen komponenten nach und nach
wieder aufgeweckt werden und getestet
werden und genau das ist in den
vergangenen tagen passiert am wochenende
dann die frohe nachricht laut dem us
wissenschaftsmagazin science ist das
weltraumteleskop zitat zurück demnach
hat das umschalten auf die backup as i
einheit funktioniert der nasa
mitarbeiter tom brown hatte seinem team
die frohe botschaft per mail übermittelt
habe liszt direkt danach feuer sich
darauf dass habe weitergeben das
universum erforschen hubble findet
älteste galaxien anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
diesen kanal einfach mit
dem abo button oder hier oben ist drauf
drücken unter jedem video das ist
absolut kostenlos und macht sogar schlau
also bis dann bleibt dran